[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
kenosha wisconsin braces for a possible
decision over charges in a police
involved shooting
the news as a trial date is set for the
suspected protest shooter
issues of bail have remain in full force
in effect you understand that mr
rittenhouse
ah yes sir a pharmacist charged with
ruining hundreds of doses of the coven
19 vaccine
why police say conspiracy theory might
be the motive
and new evidence could delay the trial
for the former officers charged in the
george floyd case
investigators now say they found drugs
in floyd's vehicle but the search comes
months after his death step out and face
awareness
don't shoot me please man plus our
exclusive scoop on a climber who went
through great lengths to take incredible
photos
he kept catching a break every time we
thought we were going to get to him
how the nationwide search finally ended
with an arrest
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the suspected kenosha shooter has pled
not guilty to charges stemming from the
fatal protests
kyle brainhouse is accused of killing
two people and wounding a third during
protests in
august reinhaus was released from jail
on a two million dollar bond he's now
facing seven charges including two
counts of homicide
attempted homicide endangering safety
and illegally possessing a firearm
prosecutors most recently added a
seventh charge violating curfew
the local sheriff declared a 7pm curfew
on august 24th
as people took to the streets outraged
over the police shooting of jacob blake
reinhaus appeared in court remotely from
his attorney's office for his
arraignment
your honor i would acknowledge receipted
the information
waived the reading of the information i
have went over all the potential
penalties with my client he's aware of
them
i've also e-filed um a jury demand on
count
six for a six-person jury and the 36
dollar fee
earlier today
all right thank you uh i assume then at
this point you're going to be entering
please
yes prepare to enter not guilty please
to all the charges contained there and
all right thank you very much not guilty
please to all accounts contained in the
information are noted and entered for
the record
matters shall now be counted for further
proceedings before the honorable bruce e
schrader presiding
and any and all previously imposed bond
conditions and
issues of bail have remain in full force
in effect do you understand that mr
written house
uh yes sir the judge preemptively set a
trial date for march 29th but
there will be a pre-trial hearing on
march 10th to see if it will actually
happen
i'm inquiring in the state how much
discovery and when it's going to be made
available
um i don't know if they have any other
dates but
i think to be able to try this case in
basically five weeks is kind of
ridiculous
i understand the court's policy uh with
broad uh judge schroeder is to give us a
jury trial date out of this but
we can take this up with uh the court on
that march
10th judicial pre-trial date as far as
the amount of discovery
attorney richards um i do have uh a
external hard drive that contains uh
reports and videos
that i can get to you uh if you want to
shoot me an email or give me a call
we can make arrangements for that in the
next day or two sounds good
and now kenosha is bracing for more
possible unrest as we learned
no officers will be charged in the blate
in the jacob blake shooting
a kenosha police officer shot blake
seven times as blake was getting into an
suv during a domestic dispute
police say blake resisted arrest and
found a knife in the floor of his
vehicle
blake was hospitalized and paralyzed but
survived the kenosha county district
attorney
says he spoke to blake over the decision
to decline to file charges against
officer
rustenzky charges will not be filed
against blake as well
city officials have barricaded the
courthouse and the national guard
has been activated the emergency
resolution
comes as officials try to avoid a repeat
of violence
terry austin has more on possible civil
action the local government could be
facing
brian attorneys for two of the august
shooting victims
let a court know they plan to sue
investigators say the two men were
shot by rittenhouse during the summer
protest in kenosha
one of the men was killed the other
survived
attorneys representing their families
each filed 10 million dollar claim
notices the notices are typically
precursors
to lawsuits the claims accuse the city
and county
of being negligent in their response to
the unrest
joining us now is criminal defense
attorney mike corbonics along with terry
austin terry how successful do you
believe these civil charges against the
city and the county could be you know
brian i think they could be
very successful from a factual
standpoint
we know that the police said to written
house
thank you for helping us they didn't
stop to even
question him about why he was carrying a
gun or what his age was
and we know later that rittenhouse
walked right by the police
and held his hands up and they did not
stop him
despite the fact that there were people
who were saying
this person just shot two people and
finally from a legal perspective brian
negligence is just not reasonable care
and we can tell from
what happened factually that these
police officers
did not act reasonably now mike like i
said we just found out there will be no
charges against the officer
who shot jacob blake your initial
reaction to that
it's rather surprising with everything
that we know so far
it it's very unusual you know brian it's
so hard
as criminal defense attorneys when we
see
these factual patterns we see every day
and
our clients we fight so hard for our
clients to minimize the exposure and
danger especially when someone
without a gun is shot in the back
several times it's a very surprising
outcome
but then again we have to think of this
as lawyers and as lawyers we do not know
what evidence was presented to the grand
jury at this time
for them to to decide either not to file
the charges or bring them before the
grand jury or what evidence they have
but it's rather surprising yeah it's
shocking and shocking
as well shocking definitely what i would
use uh terry do you want to give a quick
bit about your reaction as well
yeah i think it's offensive i think that
the d.a saying that you know this was a
domestic violence
is not enough this was seven shots and
that is you know charges should be
brought
now to california where a judge has
ordered a civil lawsuit against actor
danny masterson
must go through the church of
scientology arbitration
four women are assuming that that 70s
show actor and the church
claiming they were sexually assaulted
masterson is a well-known member of the
church of scientology
the women also claimed they were stalked
and intimidated by members of the church
according to variety magazine the judge
ordered that the civil complaints must
be resolved through quote religious
arbitration
due to an existing agreement masterson
is criminally charged with raping three
women in california
he's scheduled to be arraigned on
wednesday
one of the trials for the so-called
doomsday cult mom has been delayed
lori valo dabel will now face a
misdemeanor trial in august
after her first on felony charges valo's
accused of covering up and destroying
evidence in connection with the deaths
of her two children another hearing for
her case
is scheduled for wednesday valo and her
husband chad day bell
are seeking to disqualify the prosecutor
they're both being held
in custody but neither are facing murder
charges
still ahead on law and crime daily new
evidence filed in the george floyd case
what it means for the trial of the four
former officers
and later an exclusive look into a
climber accused of felony trespassing
the viral photos you don't want to miss
[Music]
welcome back the highly anticipated
trial in the george floyd case could be
pushed back
as new evidence is discovered according
to newly released court documents
investigators search the car george
floyd was sitting in for a second time
and
reportedly found drugs containing
methamphetamine and fentanyl the
minneapolis police officer said they
found floyd in may
because he allegedly used the
counterfeit twenty dollar bill in a shop
he died after the officers kneel on his
neck for more than eight minutes
step out and face away please don't
shoot me
step out and face away please don't
shoot me
please don't shoot me man step out and
face away not shoot me i'm not shooting
step out
the second search of floyd's suv
reportedly turned up white pills
an empty package of goodnight gummies
and packages of opioid addiction
medication
the now fire officers are scheduled to
go to trial in march
but their defense attorneys are seeking
to delay it until this summer
prosecutors are not objecting a hearing
on the matter is scheduled for thursday
terry call me suspicious but a second
search found
all of these drugs in meds there's
definitely going to be a lot of
questions about why they weren't found
in the first search
right and rightly so brian i mean they
were thinking that there were possible
drugs
back on may 25th when this all occurred
and now it's seven months later and they
do this second
search and all of a sudden they found
all of these drugs i'm not saying
that in fact they weren't there
initially but it does
look very suspect and as a matter of
fact i think an
argument can be made and should be made
that this
evidence should not be admitted at any
trial because they fail to show any
chain of custody so i think this is very
suspicious
yeah the chain of custody argument works
but mike the other argument i think
that's why we might not hear this in
trial
is it even relevant as to what drugs may
and medication
may or may not have been in his vehicle
at the time he was killed like how does
that play into this case
i i have no idea how they're going to
get this in that to any relevance
we just heard in the clip that was just
played the reason they
pulled him over was not drugs and
obviously these drugs were not
suspicious if it took them seven months
to find it
so i don't think it comes into play i'd
be shocked if a judge
let that in because it has no relevance
to the matter
yeah drugs in his system i can see that
being relevant considering homicide
drugs in his car
i don't know especially the officers
don't know it at the time but we'll see
how that plays out
now to wisconsin where prosecutors say a
former pharmacist has admitted to
purposefully destroying vials of the
copen 19 vaccine
stephen brattenberg is accused of
spoiling 500 doses of the vaccine
at a hospital in grafton brattenberg is
facing felony charges of criminal damage
to property
and recklessly endangering safety police
say he told him
that he intentionally tried to ruin the
vaccines because they didn't
because he didn't believe they were safe
a detective described brattenberg as an
admitted conspiracy theorist
he appeared in court remotely for his
initial hearing
an email from the defendant where he
gave a statement that he'd removed
these vials from refrigeration he'd done
so on two occasions his intent in doing
so
was to render them inert because he'd
formed this belief that they were unsafe
that the rna
method of creating these um medications
rendered them
unsafe i know that it involved 500 doses
i know that it was approximately 50
vials i know that some people
or at least i learned that some people
have been injected with this substance
i don't know who i don't know exactly
how many and i i submit that those
records would um be forthcoming from
aurora hospital
in some form depending on whether or not
we need to
get additional court orders for that
that's all somewhat in play right now
i know that the defendant was arrested
beca after the police went to his
residence he
was pretty cooperative and fully
admitted to everything he'd done he gave
them a full confession that
he'd done exactly this his intent was to
destroy the medication
he did the things that he was accused of
coming up on law and crime daily an
elusive photographer tries to avoid
police detection
what it took to capture these incredible
shots and the man behind them
[Music]
next
[Music]
an army veteran is in jail in arizona
charged with berkeley but
this isn't a typical case about breaking
in the man is accused of breaking into
landmarks to take photos
angela levy spoke with a detective about
how they nabbed this
thrill-seeking photographer in a long
crime exclusive
yeah brian this is kind of a crazy case
remember that movie catch me if you can
it's kind of like that
police track the man known as drifter
shoots across the country
and then they finally caught him
there's no dispute the photos drifter
shoots posts on social media are
interesting
even breathtaking but police say the way
the photographer
takes the photos is a crime he's using
types of pry bars
lock pick mechanisms sets he's disabling
security cameras motion sensors
he's physically damaging buildings that
he's entering
and then going to the top of the
building
and then the police are being notified
cincinnati police detective jeff ruberg
started investigating drifter shoots in
november after a security
guard spotted a man with a backpack
inside this office building the great
american tower
police spent hours in the building with
canines trying to find him
he spent eight and a half hours in that
building he eluded the police and
escaped on foot police say they
identified drifter shoots as this man
isaac wright he was discharged from the
army last year
and had attended seer school which
stands for survival
evasion resistance and escape ruberg
says wright's been traveling the country
taking risks when he climbs on bridges
and onto the edge of skyscrapers to take
photos
we believe he has counter surveillance
we believe he has friends that will be
on the ground if he's on a building
breaking into a building
this video from new orleans shows a man
who appears to be right climbing a
landmark
police tracked wright using license
plate readers starting in melbourne
florida
then to new orleans louisiana where they
missed him then it was on to houston
texas
cities in new mexico and finally to
wynonna arizona
where state troopers finally caught up
with him on december 17th
he kept catching a break every time we
thought we were going to get to him
he was he was caught finally and that
was only
with the persistence of the arizona
department of public safety
and when we come back we'll show you
more of those buildings that led police
in cincinnati to iding
isaac wright plus what other charges he
could face
and where as long crime daily continues
[Music]
we've been telling you about an army
veteran who's been traveling the country
taking photos from atop landmarks and
skyscrapers
angela levy has the exclusive on what
led him to being identified
you know brian nobody knew who drifter
shoots was he was even interviewed by a
television station in michigan
and at that time he was wearing a mask
he was also selling the photographs that
he took
on his website but police say they
actually identified wright after he
broke into the great american tower in
cincinnati
last november they say isaac wright was
in the building for eight and a half
hours even climbing into the crown on
top
cincinnati police examined his social
media accounts and figured out his
identity
all of the photos are now evidence they
say he had previously broken
into the great american ballpark where
the cincinnati reds played nearby
he scaled a wall he he came over in this
area over here
made sure the coast was clear you could
see he's got his backpack
and then he actually scales the wall
climbs the wall
and now he's in the stadium by himself
in the evening hours
it was around 7 pm he climbs to the tip
of a light post we're not exactly sure i
think it might be this one or this one
he dangles his feet and he takes a
picture of the stadium and calls it
angels in the outfield
now isaac wright could face even more
charges in cincinnati after the case go
to
the grand jury right now he's facing
charges of possessing criminal tools and
burglary for breaking into that office
building and he is also facing a charge
for trespassing that's felony
trespassing
in michigan brian police say he traveled
across the country
which other cities appear on his social
media
yeah brian there are a lot of photos on
his social media and there are really
cool photos but police say it's all in
the way he is taking them
we found some photographs from new york
los angeles philadelphia
places in florida many cities across the
country even dallas texas
my panel is back with me for a legal
analysis on this case
mike i'm looking at some of these photos
gorgeous photos beautiful photos but
isn't it the crime of how he got
on top of these buildings not
necessarily taking the photos so
can they really use his social media to
prosecute him for all of these cities
if they don't know how he got into the
buildings i think it's going to be
it's going to be interesting i think
it's going to be very interesting how
they come about
the prosecution and what's going to be
admissible evidence it's going to be
very difficult but
one thing is this guy obviously likes
getting as high as he can
absolutely now terry this catch me if
you can story ended with a catch
how is he going to have cases is he
going to have cases all over the country
basically i know anjanet
named some of the photos from different
cities
but right now michigan seems the only
one going after him
well i do think other cities will begin
to go after him
i mean his attorney is going to have to
see if he can defend him
in these various cases which might arise
his name
by the way drifter shoots is an amazing
name for what he's doing
but i think they're going to have to
show that he has
some sort of you know mental illness or
some
other incapacity because he doesn't
really understand that what he's doing
is against the law and if he
does understand that then in fact i
think they're going to have to do some
sort of plea
because what he's doing is taking up
time and resources
of the authorities and you know that's
against the law
yeah i definitely think and this is just
me spitballing i think he appreciates
that it's wrong i think he's just a bit
of a thrill seeker and maybe that's why
he got caught up in this uh angelette
had isaac right been approached by
police before this incident or before
being arrested
yeah we were actually told that he had
been stopped in north carolina
and charged with some type of
trespassing count there
and i should mention also that he could
be extradited back to ohio
this week and police also believe that
other people
are involved now mike we're talking
about going from major city to major
city which also means state to state
and if he's traveling state to state
with the purpose of committing a crime
could he run afoul with federal charges
i think he could and i think one of the
reasons he could is one of the bridges
actually is the border between the
united states is my understanding in
canada
so there's going to be all kinds of
different territorial jurisdictional
questions here it's very interesting
case
especially since one of the things
they're concerned about is at these
borders
he breached security but he's trained to
do that
prior to his becoming a drifting shooter
exactly if he's if he's crossing over
the border especially depending on where
he is on that bridge
that's definitely federal charges i
don't think the canadians are going to
come
after him though uh probably gonna stay
here in the states all together
uh terry for you people are gonna say
hey he put his own life at risk but the
reckless endangerment could also be from
him falling and hitting people
underneath him so that could be a
potential charge as well right
absolutely he endangered the lives not
only of himself
obviously because what he's doing is
very risky but if he had dropped any
equipment or
even if he had himself fallen and
someone was trying to save him and they
got injured
he definitely was being reckless and i
think there are some charges that can be
brought against him state and federal
we'll see how it works out and jeanette
terry mike thanks for joining us and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you